my talk will involve next-generation
sequencing for diagnosis and
surveillance of emerging infections I
just want to start with some disclosures
I do get research support for passage
and discovery from ebba Diagnostics I am
also on the scientific advisory board
for to genomic companies so for the
summary of my talk will start out by
talking about what i mean by unbiased
metagenomic next-generation sequencing
or NGS for infectious disease diagnosis
well then talk about a bound for Maddox
analysis pipeline which has been
developed for passage detection from
sequencing data will then talk about
rapid pathogen identification using a
new technology called real-time nanopore
sequencing we'll go over a few clinical
case reports we'll talk a little bit of
applications for pathogen discovery and
then finally we will end by discussing a
project called the CIA p.m. project
which stands for California initiative
to advanced precision medicine a way to
implement this clinically validated NGS
test for diagnosis of infectious disease
in hospitalized patients and the
motivation for this is that there is a
great clinical unmet need in that for
many acute and life-threatening
infectious diseases as you can see here
on the slide including pneumonia
diarrheal disease meningitis
encephalitis and sepsis we really lack
diagonally sensitive or specific
diagnostic tests or the tests that we do
have tend to be delayed and as a result
we miss up to perhaps twenty five
percent of pneumonias about the fifty
percent of cases of diarrheal disease
and for a disease like encephalitis up
to eighty percent of the time the cause
can remain unknown despite extensive
testing in the hospital it's also no
I'll describe that even for well
characterized syndromes such as
hemorrhagic fever and sepsis for
instance up to twenty percent of time
the cause remains unknown despite
testing so our approach is instead of
using kind of the traditional infectious
disease paradigm of one test per target
so for instance one influenza test
detect influenza our approach is to use
a single nucleic acid sequencing test to
detect nearly all microbes and in
principle because all of these micro
that you see here bacteria viruses fungi
and parasites that cause human disease
are made of DNA there's no particular
reason why in a single nucleic acid test
or a single DNA based sequencing test we
can diagnose or potentially diagnose all
of these agents of course we're missing
one agent which are pre ons which are
protein based instead of being dna-based
however we can really detect the vast
majority of agents that cause human
disease so our approach is known as
metagenomic next-generation sequencing
and called metagenomic because the
general idea is we wanted to text
sequences that represent all kinds of
genomes bacterial viral parasitic or
fungal all of these pathogens
microorganisms that cause infectious
diseases however is you might expect
from human clinical samples most of what
you'll be sequencing and Amanda genomic
approach are probably go to be from the
host and this poses a big problem which
will go into impute in later slides so
the approach is to is a brute-force
approach involving random or shotgun
sequencing of all of the DNA and RNA all
of nucleic acid in clinical samples this
enables us to not only detect but to
potentially to actually reconstruct the
entire genomic sequence of nearly any
and all pathogens at once what's made
this technology feasible over the past
couple of years has been the vest
increases in sequencing capacity namely
on an instrument like the my seek we can
generate about 40 30 to 40 million reads
per run on an instrument like the high
seek we can generate more than a billion
reads per run and even on point of care
smaller instruments which will go into
future slides such as the Oxford
nanopore min I on we can still generate
about a hundred thousand sequence reads
per run and then ultimate goal of this
is that we would be able to accelerate
day diagnosis by using these
next-generation sequencing tests and the
goal would be to impact clinical
decision making this is a process which
is known as precision medicine and the
general idea is that instead of
empirically treating patients with
infectious diseases meaning that we
treat them without really knowing what
the diagnosis is trying to make a best
guess we are able to implement a
comprehensive yet specific test to make
a very
accurate diagnosis and by doing so we
could then provide both early as well as
targeted treatment that would be
cost-effective and actionable and
ultimately this would result in lower
health care costs and improve patient
outcomes so the general approach for
identifying pathogens on the basis of
their specific DNA sequence is shown
here in this slide when we start out
with raw sequencing data we then clean
up those reads in the process in called
pre-processing we didn't identify the
background which as you might expect
from human clinical samples or human
reads we think computationally subtract
after competition subtracting those
background reads we then identify
pathogen specific reads reads that may
correspond to viruses bacteria fungi and
parasites that may be potential signals
that these microorganisms are present in
the clinical sample and then this would
ultimately result in detection and
diagnosis now traditionally this has
been a big computational bottleneck in
particular two of the procedures
identifying human background reads as
well as identifying pathogen
specifically is by aligning these
millions of sequences to extremely large
databases have been a big computational
challenge that have taken days to weeks
and as you might expect unlike other
fields such as cancer where perhaps
having a delay of a few days is
acceptable infectious diseases with
critically ill patients is real time is
really of the essence for making a
diagnosis so we would really want a
computational pipeline that can actually
identify agents within minutes to hours
as opposed to daves two weeks so partly
to address this challenge we developed
the diaphragmatic pipeline that we call
sir p sequence-based ultra rapid
pathogen identification the goal of this
pipeline is to analyze millions of
next-generation sequences in minutes
hours and be able to provide data that
would be interpreted by clinical
personnel such as doctors and laboratory
directors and in a way this directly
addresses the computational analysis
bottleneck we streamline the algorithms
we actually use extremely fast
algorithms that are orders of magnitude
faster than then traditional algorithms
for
analyzing the data I should also mention
that this is not the only pipeline
that's available other groups have also
been working on and have developed
pipelines as well but this is a this
pipeline was designed from the get go to
be something that would be streamlined
and would enable analysis you know
within minutes to hours we also have a
clinical version called sir p plus which
is an active development this goes over
kind of the process of how we actually
do the sequencing and then do the
analysis to make an identification so if
you focus on the left side part of the
slide we basically start out with a
clinical sample extract the DNA and RNA
we generate the library and then we
sequence it and then if going to the
right side for the analysis those are
the steps of the analysis as you can see
we trim the data we assemble the data
into larger larger sequences or longer
sequences called contigs we then remove
human sequences because that represents
the background in this particular test
and then we identify pathogens such as
as you can see in that in kind of the
third third panel on the right fourth
panel on the right you can see example
of virus a bacterium a parasite and a
fungus and we do that by aligning the
sequences to very large reference
databases we finally are able to
classify them and if it becomes very
important because you not only want to
identify say a virus but you want to
make sure that your identification is
specific so we use analytical methods to
classify the the hits properly and that
way we can kind of report the results in
kind of an easy to use visualization
kind of web-based visualization tools
that we've developed so I want to focus
now on specifically what we do for
clinical interpretation results
reporting because this is really a
critical aspect of the of the analysis
in that we not only want to analyze
millions of sequence reads we want to be
able to provide data that would be
usable they'll be usable by those
working in medicine or in public health
so what we do is we do things such as
filter sequences that happen to be Miss
annotated in the databases we are able
to tag some of what we call the metadata
The Associated data with the sequences
so we can identify
five for instance which which of these
organisms are colonizers or which one of
their more likely to be pathogens we're
able to provide a front-end
visualization tool in a web-based
interface we're able to do as I
mentioned before accurate classification
so we make sure that all over hits are
accurate and precise and we also have
implemented measure measures to improve
processing speed as well as provide
different implementations of the
software such as on the laptop and
potentially on the cloud so I want to go
a little bit into the software so the
visualization aspect of the software
that we built is called sir peeve is
this sense for visualization this is
kind of a web-based visualization tool
that enables you to look at next
generation sequencing data one of the
advantages of using circuit is is that
you don't need to be a programmer or
bound format assist to be able to run
this software we actually now have
clinically certified technicians or
actually running and using this software
on a daily basis this gives you some
example of some of the how what the data
may look like so what you actually see
here this is a heat map of hits where
typically hits are in kind of basically
more reddish orange colors whereas no
hits or negative results are shown in
green and yellow as you can see here
these are basically eight samples and
the samples are arranged their
designated 67 to 74 and they're arranged
in in columns and what you see on the
left side are actually the hits two
different viruses and as you can see
simply at a glance we can see that
sample number 71 for instance has a
strong hit a hundred and eight reads
that align tues I re bola virus and
indeed this was actually a sample from a
patient who was infected with Ebola
hemorrhagic fever or Ebola virus disease
now we we don't have about 50 for lab
we're not actually we are processing a
sample but the samples are inactivated
before they're sent from Africa to the
United States for analysis but you can
see here this is an example of how at a
glance you can see you know that this is
a patient that is infected with desire
Ebola virus I want to
a little bit about Clea so and this is
important because all clinical
diagnostic tests need to be done within
a certain regulatory framework called
CLIA at least in the United States clear
stands for clinical laboratory
Improvement Amendments this is a federal
regulatory framework for clinical
laboratory testing that took effect in
1992 Cleo laboratories are accredited
dated or certified by inspection
agencies so for instance are clear
laboratory which is the UC San Francisco
microbiology laboratory is certified by
the College of American Pathologists
minimum standards under which all
clinical laboratories operate and it
really requires validation and quality
assurance for all laboratory tests that
are used in clinical care now this would
include the validation of the sequencing
metagenomic and gssa that I've been
talking about and it's really essential
that this be done in a CLIA environment
so that we are able to actually
implement this clinically and be able to
report results on diagnostic results for
patients so what we've done is in
addition to the actual pipeline and the
actual protocols we've managed to move
the entire workflow into a CLIA
certified laboratory and the goal is
that everything would be done in a CLIA
environment if we run by clinically a
licensed scientists as well as done in a
regulated fashion the analysis is done
as well so the analysis is not
independent this but it is rather a
critical part of this and the goal would
be to have a test that has a total
turnaround time of between 12 hours in
two days this shows you kind of the kind
of the broad applicability of this
approach so what you've actually see
here you actually see here results from
analysis of samples from six different
patients so two patients who are in the
first row I actually have nasal
infection either two children from UCSF
with nasal disease with actually a
respiratory upper respiratory illness on
the lower part of the slide you can
actually see these are samples from four
patients with acute febrile illness from
Africa and as you can see on that on the
top two you can actually see that we can
detect two viruses that are linked to
respiratory disease and children met
animo virus and run a virus type 78
in addition from the plasma or blood
samples from the patients from Africa
with fever and and in some cases sepsis
we can identify infection by add no
virus by a bacterium called hemolysis
influenza by another bacterium called
Salmonella typhi which is the cause of
typhoid fever this was a patient with
typhoid fever as well as even a parasite
and what you see here is the lower right
is a box showing analysis and sequencing
analysis of a patient who has a cute
malaria and is affected with the cause
of that which is Plasmodium falciparum
when I show there are actually just four
of the several many chromosomes that are
in part of the Plasmodium organism so to
summarize ultimately what we want to do
here is to provide more timely diagnosis
that will result in improved clinical
outcomes and we're aiming really here
for 12 to 24 hour turnaround time now we
don't envision that this is really going
to be a front line test that's done an
emergency department but this would be
potentially a second line test after
you've already done the kind of point of
care tests or the immediate tests and
the patient is still lacks a diagnosis
you could then send this assay which
potentially can be done in a timeframe
that would be better than kind of
existing methods which involve kind of
turnaround times that that may be in
within you know several days to weeks
such as send out molecular testing even
antibiotic resistance testing and
culture I want to give you a few
examples here so this was a this is
actually Josh Osborne and the photo was
given to me courtesy of the Osborne
family he was a 14 year old gentleman
who had three hospitalizations over four
months spent 44 days in the ICU
intensive care unit had over 100
inconclusive diagnostic tests for
different pathogens had three impaired
treatments to no effect eventually
underwent a brain biopsy and induced
coma for his disease and at a cost as
you can see they're significant costs
and we so we were able to when he was
critically ill we were able to look at a
cerebral spinal fluid sample from this
boy
and to make a long story short we will
to identify within 48 hours that his
turbo spinal fluid by the NGSS a wasn't
it was in fact harbored an organism
called leptospira centrist i which is
the cause of a disease called
leptospirosis which is a bacterial
disease of the central nervous system he
was cured within two weeks after his
diagnosis from NGS diagnosis with
appropriate treatment which in this case
ironically is simply IV penicillin
intravenous penicillin this is a report
that was published in the New England
Journal of Medicine I want to show you
what it actually looks like on our new
software sir peeve is so you can see
here this was on on the left you can
actually see the left column actually is
a DNA sample from cerebral spinal fluid
from Josh you can see here that the top
Cade is indeed leptospira centrist I
which was the organism that caused his
encephalitis meningitis this is another
way to look at the data this is called a
krona plot which basically displays kind
of the various species and genera and
families of organisms that were detected
as you can see here the majority in fact
the vast majority of the reeds aligned
to let the sparrow this is looking at
kind of the again the DNA portion of his
sequencing data I want to go over
another example because as an example to
show that we we can not only detect
bacterial this is actually a case of a
viral infection this gentleman was a 55
year old male with deafness and
behavioral change he had a bone marrow
transplant in May of 2013 mid-october he
developed rapidly progressive hearing
loss he actually went from completely
normal hearing to completely deaf within
two to three weeks was testing for
common agents viruses that cause that
may cause this or negative he was
treated empirically with antiviral
medications antibiotics intravenous
immunoglobulin and steroids to no effect
over the next few weeks his symptoms
became worse he developed nausea fatigue
persistent hearing loss and then depress
irritable mood actually a personality
change which was very unusual for the
patient according to his wife and was
finally sedated under the UK Mental
Health Act
in he had an MRI scan of his brain late
December which show that he had
developed some abnormal signal in his
mid brain and his thalamus bilaterally
on both sides so he had a brain biopsy
that was performed to make a diagnosis
but you see here is actually a slice
across his MRI scan and shown in the
white arrows are some hyperintensities
that are seen on imaging which are
abnormal which are found in the midbrain
and thalamus was clearly he had some
brain process neurological process a
pathologic process that was likely the
cause of his symptoms and so we were
able to look at in this case brain
biopsy tissue from him and we were able
to identify using the NGSS a that this
was a case of Astro virus encephalitis
when Astro viruses are actually emerging
viruses emerging causes of encephalitis
over the past year now there have
actually been several case reports of
Astro viruses causing illness primarily
in in both children and adults who are
immunocompromised and this gentleman was
immunocompromised and using to hear what
you see on the upper right is you can
actually see staining specifically for
this Astro virus he had a strain that
was called the VA one strain or the HMO
see strain and you can see here that is
shown there in pink is kind of a
phylogenetic analysis of the sequence
from his virus and you can see her fits
in basically with a particular clade
that has been linked to encephalitis and
syphilitic disease now he came he was an
adult primarily are the other cases of
this Astro virus had be found in
children because actually after viruses
are actually common viral causes of
viral diarrhea in children it's only
recently that now these Astro viruses
have been linked to potentially fatal
encephalitis or brain infections in
adults and children what's interesting
is that the two closest relatives animal
relatives to this virus or this
particular quaid our mink Astro virus
has shown their kind of as well as a
bovine Astro viruses which you can see
there that they're actually closely
related by phylogenetic analysis what's
interesting is that in both minks and
cows that these viruses have been shown
to actually cause encephalitis in
animals as well so he was started on
antiviral therapy and intravenous
immunoglobulin but unfortunately there's
no treatment for a stove ours is so
despite treatment he passed away four
months after his diagnosis however this
is a good point I would like to make is
that had there been a treatment the fact
that we will to use a comprehensive test
that was able to pick this up might have
made a difference had there been an
effective treatment for this disease
this is another case so we went over a
case of a bacterial infection of our own
section I want to now talk about a
parasitic infection this is a case of
hemorrhagic encephalitis which actually
isn't bad as it really sounds I mean it
really is bleeding in the brain as a
result of infection this is a 15 year
old girl with type 1 diabetes who had
seven days of headache vomiting arm
weakness and confusion she developed
these very large hemorrhagic lesions on
MRI scan you can see here are shown as
one slice where you see the entire area
and white is basically a lesion and she
had expensive diagnostic testing that
was negative and the clinicians who
evaluate her when she came in said
thought that this was a classic
presentation for what we call the
hemorrhagic form of an autoimmune
disease called a cute d violating
encephalomyelitis so she was actually
given steroids which is appropriate if
she had in an autoimmune disease
unfortunately she did not and she
actually had an infectious disease so
after five days she actually got worse
and was actually markedly worse so had a
brain biopsy that was done and it turns
out that this was a case of balamuthia
and sefa lightest so for those of you
who are probably not familiar with this
bug this is one of the causes of what is
known colloquially as brain eating
amoeba this was a this is a disease
which is actually acquired by exposure
to the soil she may have been she may
have acquired this while playing in the
playground for instance and so she
actually had by the sequencing tasked us
more than six thousand reads that
aligned to a specific sequence from the
pair
site allamuchy I manager Lars she also
had the brain biopsy analysis pathologic
analysis which showed that numerous
examples of the amoeba you can see here
kind of in a blow-up this is an example
of amoebic cell the cell is actually
insist form in the brain tissue if you
actually look on the right that's
actually the cell kind of went in the
vegetative form was actually active and
unfortunately the diagnosis was made by
day seven but despite combination
antibiotic therapy antifungal therapy
anti amoebic therapy she developed
intracranial hypertension cardiac arrest
and died so we actually wanted to go
back and see you know could we have made
a difference if perhaps could we have
diagnosed it earlier and if so would it
have made a difference if we could have
made the diagnosis perhaps one day one
when she initially came to the hospital
so we actually took a look at her
cerebral spinal fluid taken at day one
and was quite interesting there was the
answer is actually no based on what was
available at the time with respect to
the reference databases if you recall
the way we're able to make an
identification here is we generate
millions of reeds but then we align them
to a reference now so therefore you're
tough is really only as good as your
reference database and it actually turns
out that they're very very few sequences
to balamuthia that we're existing in the
reference database as of six months ago
now in the meantime my laboratory is
actually working on the genome sequence
the entire genome of bowel mutia which
is about 50 mega bases in size and
what's interesting is once you include
that that particular genome in the
reference database then you actually are
able to detect the bug detect sequences
from this particular organism on day one
as you can see on the left side where we
detected 20 reads from the cerebral
spinal fluid had there been the genome
in the reference database but zero given
with the existing two databases and it's
really highlights that microbial
reference sequences are really critical
for this procedure I want to switch
gears a little bit I want to move into
kind of a new technology that we've been
working with for diagnosing emerging
infections and this is called the net
poor and the technology is called
nanopore sequencing what we've done here
is we've actually taken the same
protocol that we've been using on an
illuminant instrument that's the
traditional protocol for diagnosing this
disease and we've been moving it on to
the men I on an Oxford nanopore the
advantages of putting this on a nanopore
is unlike the my seek which has a 24 to
48 hour turnaround time we're actually
able to go from sample to getting an
answer within under six hours and what
the netip or really is is it's kind of a
USB aside slightly larger than a USB
size stick that enables you to do
effectively real-time sequencing
analysis so the difference between that
and the more kind of commonly used
technology which is Illumina sequencing
is that you can actually analyze the
data as soon as you start sequencing it
whereas for Illumina sequencing you
actually have to wait until the data is
fully sequenced before you can analyze
it and that's why there's such a big
difference in the time to initial
detection under six hours for the men I
on Oxford nanopore and more than 20
hours at a minimum for Illumina
sequencing room so this gives you an
example where we are able to detect bio
reads reads in this case from a plasma
sample from two patients who have acute
fever if two febrile illness with we're
able to detect within six minutes that
one patient was infected with
chikungunya virus and on the right you
can see within eight minutes were able
to detect infection by Ebola virus and
again I want to stress that we're using
this we're using meta genomic NGS in
other words we're not targeting
specifically chingling a virus or
bolivars we're simply sequencing
everything in the sample doing real-time
sequence analysis and seeing if we can
detect the organism as soon as possible
what also was quite impressive by some
of our work is that is that basically
that we're able to get this kind of near
complete genome coverage with really
high C confident sequence assembly you
can see here that this is showing you
chikungunya virus where we're able to
basically with very high identity be
able to identify chingu new virus and if
you have sufficient coverage you can
actually identify and sequence the organ
is
accurately I want to talk a little bit
about chikungunya virus because chingu
nia virus is an emerging viral infection
this is a study that we just published
actually an emergency emerging
infectious diseases in 2015 this is
these are cases a case epidemic curve of
chingu Nia virus in Puerto Rico this is
a done in collaboration with American
Red Cross and as you can see here in
2014 there was actually a very large
outbreak of chikungunya virus it's
actually over the past several years has
come into the Caribbean at specifically
in imported disease from Africa and
areas of Asia now it's actually in the
Western Hemisphere for the fur probably
the second time but but now it's more
recently emerged in the Western
Hemisphere and what we did is we decide
to use sequencing to identify to look at
three cases shown there in the red
asterisks so what we did is we actually
did both PCR as well as next generation
sequencing analysis of chikungunya virus
positive blood donors and what what's
interesting is that you can now we can
not only detect chingu new virus by a
PCR polymerase chain reaction but that
given the high titers of the virus in
infected patients we can actually
assemble the genome the entire genome of
this virus and why would you want to do
so well there a couple of reasons one
reason for identifying the genome as you
can see here the next slide is that and
getting a sequence of the genome enables
you to do phylogenetic analysis the
place exactly where does this virus fits
in the NGS data and you can see here
that that really it fits and equate as
you might expect it fits in the clay
that's been linked to all consisting of
viruses from the Caribbean chikungunya
virus in the Caribbean so you can see
here that the printer Rico strains that
we sequenced here using either the my
seek or the min Iannetta poor are
related to previously sequence trains in
sentence the island of San martín
Martinique as well as the British Virgin
Islands all of which are part of the
Caribbean islands in addition although I
don't show it here we can also do a
technique called molecular clock
analysis we can actually use the
phylogenetic data to be able to predict
when did this virus emerge and by doing
so we were able to actually show that
this virus emerged
in sent in in the Caribbean in probably
in early 2013 so we're able to kind of
date the emergence of this virus in the
Caribbean it took 24 2013 and in Puerto
Rico to early 2014 you can refer to the
publish publication for more details so
this is basically gives you a kind of a
look at the men I on you can see here
that the menu is a little bit larger
than a USB stick but the general idea is
that this Dominion consists of a flow
cell that has a consists of a flow cell
with pores and what happens is as you
inject the library as a DNA flows
through the pores you can do real-time
sequencing analysis on your laptop ok I
also want to show that this is not only
the case the file Jake analysis is not
only the case for chingu new virus but
also works for Ebola virus and as you
can see here this is basically using
either the men ion or the my seek
instrument we're able to identify this
particularly Boulevard strain as a
strain that originated from Central
Africa from the Democratic Republic of
the Congo as you can see here in pink so
this is not the strain which is in fact
did not come from the same outbreak as
the probably the more widely known West
African outbreak which is shown here in
yellow which was the outbreak in in the
countries of Guinea Sierra Leone and
Liberia so we can biogenic analysis by
sequencing we can not only detect the
agent but do the phylogenetic analysis
to be able to precisely identify the
strain of the pathogen I want to go a
little bit more into Ebola virus so we
are currently looking using this
technique of sequencing to look at Ebola
virus samples collected from Central
Africa and it's our goal that we can use
the meta genomic NGS test as a way to
improve Ebola virus Diagnostics so what
you actually see here there was an
outbreak of Ebola virus disease in Congo
in the 2014 2014 and happen actually
happened in two provinces in the
Democrat to villages and Democrat public
of the Congo what you see here are
actually eight samples from this first
eight additional k the first eight cases
in this outbreak including the in
next case and as you can see here shown
in the red that metagenomic NGS was as
sensitive as both conventional and
real-time pcr which is the the gold
standard testing for this disease as in
the diagnosis of Ebola virus disease
we're also able to develop some
enrichment methods where we can
basically enrich samples so that we can
be able to sequence the entire genome of
the virus directly from patient samples
i also want to talk about some other
aspects of the analysis so the NGS
analysis at the NGS tests the next
generation sequencing test as they said
before is a great way to identify
pathogens in kind of in comprehensive
and unbiased fashion but what's also
interesting is that you can actually do
what we call host response analysis you
can actually look at the human portion
which we normally throw away the human
part but our idea is that we can
actually use the sequencing data that
that corresponds to the human response
to be able to identify the disease so
we're currently doing a study where
we're actually looking at samples from
patients with different types of
hemorrhagic fevers different types of
febrile illnesses from Africa so either
Ebola virus another virus called Lassa
fever virus as well as malaria to see is
can we identify potentially markers that
human by sequencing can we identify
human markers or markers of gene
expression that can help diagnose
potentially the disease now this is a
great interest part of the reason this
of great interest is that even the most
sensitive PCR tests can't really detect
Ebola virus in some cases of early
disease or before a patient has symptoms
and it's our hope that potentially by
doing this technique we can actually
identify and diagnose patients with
Ebola even before they have symptoms
which would as you might expect would
would probably very helpful with respect
to outbreak containment and infection
control so we were able to do this study
and identify that there were hundreds of
unique differentially expressed genes
called degs that were identified in
Ebola virus patients we also identified
many of the or reiterated many of the
existing pathways have been linked to a
bola virus infection and we're currently
using this information
Shin to actually develop biomarker
panels so the idea is using the
sequencing to then develop biomarker
panels that will help you diagnose or
differentially diagnose Ebola
hemorrhagic fever and distinguish it
from other causes of hemorrhagic fever
in Africa we're currently working with
two groups in West Africa to be able to
implement this potentially as a
sequencing test that could be done kind
of in in the developing world in the
point of kin point-of-care laboratories
in the developing world this gives you
another example where the same approach
doesn't necessarily apply just to Ebola
this is a manuscript that we recently
submitted where we're able to do a
signature identification for acute Lyme
disease Lyme disease is also another
infectious disease where Diagnostics is
a big problem currently the gold
standard tessa's two-tiered serological
antibody testing which is really only
good kind of two to three weeks after
the illness and doesn't really after you
develop kind of symptoms of Lyme disease
the fever and the rash and are really
not useful in the acute settings so
we're hoping on using this to develop
new tests that can diagnose the disease
in the acute setting and we're able to
show here that you can see that the
classifier panel using the gene analysis
using sequencing is specific to line as
you can see here in kind of the blue
dots this gives you another example of
where we took the samples from the
hemorrhagic fever study we identified
that a 25 gene biomarker panel we
narrowed it down to 25 genes and we then
are able to show here that those 25
genes appeared to be fairly specific for
diagnosis of Ebola virus what's
interesting here also is that you can
see of the five samples that we ran this
panel through one of them is highlighted
in the asterisk that was actually a
patient that was pcr negative so that
was actually a patient that was before
the virus was actually detectable in the
patient's blood were able to identify
that that patient at least did have a
signature of acute hemorrhagic ebola
virus infection I want to talk about
another emerging virus because a part of
the theme of this talk is discussion of
applying sequencing for emerging viral
detection I want to talk to you about
enterovirus d68 this is a very
interesting virus
it's a respiratory virus that was
initially discovered in 1960s we
recently published the paper this year
actually where we i use sequencing the
same sequencing testing to be able to
analyze samples from patients that were
infected with enterovirus d68 the other
thing that has been a link to
intervarsity 68 is a an acute flaccid
myelitis syndrome so a q4 myelitis is a
disease where mostly children they
shortly after getting an acute febrile
illness they then develop kind of a
flaccid paralysis and this can happen in
one limb it could happen in both limbs
in both arms and legs and eventually can
even progress to involving respiratory
failure so and this is was quite
alarming because it happened in
previously healthy children small subset
of children that had developed an acute
febrile illness and the other thing that
was also interesting that the timing of
the cases of this acute screw faucet
paralysis appeared to coincide with that
of a very large respiratory enterovirus
d68 outbreak that occurred last year
throughout the United States in 2014 the
months were mainly between august and
december and it the question has always
been is you know is this was is at 0 VAR
c 68 the cause or potentially the cause
of accuse us of myelitis acute flaccid
paralysis or this simply was this simply
a coincidence and this is a difficult
question to address both by hospitals
and public health agencies because
really we don't really have routine
surveillance for enterovirus infections
so this was a big mystery because it was
a nationwide outbreak of a respiratory
viral infection enterovirus d68 that
sent children to emergency departments
and yet we don't know why some children
that had a respiratory infection had in
Traverse d68 eventually did develop kind
of acute flaccid paralysis and what we
want to do is we want to use the
sequencing test to see if there really
was an association so some of the key
questions we want to answer here and I
should preface this by saying that we
didn't answer all of them in fact we're
currently there's ongoing research to
try to address some of these but one is
that is intervarsity 60 infection really
associate with
keeps us in myelitis whether there's
something special about this virus that
was detected in about fifty percent of
children with acute flaccid myelitis
ahead intervarsity fixate infection so
the other thing that was interesting was
that only fifty percent of the children
that had never see 60 infection had a
nevar sorry fifty percent the children
with acute often myelitis had a nevar
c60 intersection and so the question was
what about the other fifty percent you
know who didn't have any VAR c 68 and
yet still had a 2,000 mile itis it made
the the link much less convincing the
other question is we wanted to identify
could we use this meta genomic ngf test
two perhaps identify an alternative ed
ology as i Ray discussed you know one of
the key advantages of this test is that
we don't buy us our detection so
potentially could we have detected
perhaps another virus that may have been
missed we also wanted to determine is
whether or not we could detect the virus
and serve a spinal fluid or blood
because prior to this point it had only
been and in fact to date it primarily
has been detected only in respiratory
secretions and not in cerebral spinal
fluid or blood and then finally we
wanted to address some of the questions
of why is detection even in respiratory
secretions unreliable so as opposed to
kind of going over the case in detail I
just want to highlight a few things this
was a case where we looked at cases in
two states California and Colorado of
which the vast majority of these cases
have been described we looked at it
total of thirty seven patients from
California 16 from Colorado as you can
see not all of them had anniversary 68
in fact only the ones that are shown in
red actually had you know we're affected
were infected with enterovirus d68 and
as you can see here the ones with an
over 86 it coincided very well with the
outbreak but of course you know given
that we don't see a no varsity 60 in all
of the cases you know this still raises
sort of like a question of you know is
this really associated with acute
flaccid myelitis so one of the key
findings that we actually made in this
study which was published in Lancet
Infectious Diseases is that we actually
discovered that all of the cases of
en'var c68 in children who had a cute
casa myelitis
from a specific clade and this is a
clade which is a group of viruses as you
can see here in the phylogenetic tree
which we call clade b 1 and what you see
here in red are actually all of the
cases that we sequence of acute flaccid
my love intervarsity to give these
recruits us in my lightest patients what
you actually see in blue are actually
the cases that are from patients that
pediatric patients had only have
respiratory disease and really
highlights the fact is that you know
this virus wasn't it's not as if this
clade was only found in viruses this in
children that had it keeps us myelitis
it was really found and it has been
found quite commonly perhaps mostly in
children that have respiratory disease
only so only a certain subset of these
children actually and a very rare subset
actually developed acute flaccid
myelitis of children infected with
intervarsity 68 so these are some of the
key questions I don't want to kind of go
over the entire study but I just want to
just answer some of the questions were
answered and some we're not so one is
that we did find that there was an
association with you fussing myelitis we
found it in more than fifty percent of
patients at afm it was really the only
agent that we found in in the actually
not the only agent but the majority
agent that we found in nasal secretions
we actually did find it in blood
actually from one boy that had it in his
blood in his respiratory secretions and
also in his stool interestingly enough
we did not see it at all in civil spinal
fluid and we hypothesize that perhaps
this is because many of the samples that
were collected or are collected late in
the course of illness where you know a
child will develop a kiss-off said
myelitis but that could be easily one to
two weeks after the acute infection the
kid febrile illness so we suspect that
many of these samples were probably
collected too late although it's also
quite interesting by using our
metagenomic NGSS a we didn't detect any
evidence of any alternative etiology so
with respect to infectious ideology so
far enterovirus d68 is still our best
candidate I just want to go over some
recent unpublished data this is done in
collaboration a laboratory of dr. ken
Tyler at the University of Colorado what
we did here is we wanted to demonstrate
a mouse model of enterovirus d68 and
so what we did is we actually took two
samples from the clade b 1 strain that
was found in the children with you
Father myelitis shown there in u.s.
Missouri us Illinois we also injected
with the prototype strains of the virus
and to make a long story short we we've
been able to reproduce this in a subset
of my set are infected inoculated with
this virus we can actually cause our we
can see a limb paralysis in fact
symptoms that resemble that scene in the
children and although this is very early
data it is actually quite suggestive and
confirmatory studies are underway so I
want to summarize the points that I've
made one is that I believe that
metagenomic NGS or next-generation
sequencing is a very promising approach
for diagnosis infectious disease new
clinical bio informatics is such a
syrupy can greatly improve computational
turnaround times and make these
accessible technologies accessible for
clinical and public health laboratories
NGS for pathogen detection discovery is
only the first step as you can see with
the enterovirus d68 story the hard work
is yet to follow and finally I feel that
many regulatory technical challenges
remain for this technology but they have
evolved to where we can really implement
them clinically and for use in both
clinical medicine and public health I
want to finally end by acknowledging all
of the collaborators and members of my
lab who are involved in this work they
include the members of my laboratory who
are shown in red collaborators
especially a technology with the
Colorado for the intervarsity 68 work
and others as well as funding by the NIH
with a UC discovery award an Abbott
pathogen discovery award and the
California initiative to advanced
precision medicine award thank you very
much and I would be happy to take
questions thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I'd like
to remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions like
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can first
question is what is the approximate cost
and next-generation sequencing diagnosis
approached her patients that's a very
difficult that's a very it's a great
question it's very difficult and it
probably takes a nuanced answer for
which I don't have a huge amount of time
I can tell you that we with respect to
the actual laboratory cost it's really
bits really the cost of the sequencing
and the cost of having say if you want
to use this clinically of having a CLIA
scientist or clinically licensed
technician to run the assay now we've
actually estimated that you know at
current kind of market costs that the
actual cost of running the assay can be
as low as about $300 three hundred to
four hundred dollars now of course in
practical terms you know it may be much
more expensive giving issues of having
it run in a clinical laboratory etc but
with respectively the actual cost is a
couple of hundred dollars meaning that
it is more expensive than say a PCR
polymerase chain reaction assay dental
laboratory but actually not too not too
much more expensive i would say probably
three to five times more expensive than
then a PCR test which as you know only
looks for one or a few agents okay next
to have please kindly differentiate
between emerging and re-emerging
infections because your topic today was
centered on emerging infection while you
are also discussing the emerging
infections this is again a great
question really for so it depends on
what you define as emerging infections
for instance if you can you may argue
for instance that virtually all of the
amal of the infections or kind of the
outbreaks that have occurred over the
past so vast majority of them that
occurred over the past ten years are
really really in the sense that so to
give an example you know many would
consider Ebola virus to be an emerging
infection and yet you know bulevar was
discovered more than 30 years ago and
this is really a reimagine now with
respect to emerging infections those are
usually by those are usually caused by
truly novel pathogens or novel agents
have not been seen before at least in
yeah in humans aren't or in the human
population so some examples of that
would include for instance sars
coronavirus and mers coronavirus
potentially avian influenza h5n1 etc but
arguably most of the infections that
we're concerned about that may cause
outbreaks are probably reimagine in that
we already know about them it's just
that we we don't really have you really
broad Diagnostics that can kind of
detect all possible agents at once
although one simple thing I do want to
highlight is that this particular
approach the use of NGS next-generation
sequencing is broad enough so that we
can detect for instance sequences from
very divergent pathogens usually viruses
that that may differ significantly from
things that are present in reference
databases so a good example of that is
where we use this to identify a new
hemorrhagic fever virus or a putative
hemorrhagic fever virus called the Congo
virus be ASCO NGO and I would recommend
you take a look at it we published that
in plos pathogens in 2012 or used a
technique and and that would arguably be
called an emerging infection because
that that virus had never before been
identified in either humans or animals I
I would like to thank you dr. chu for
your presentation do you have any final
comments to share with us sure I just
want to end by saying that there's a lot
of interest in this technology I do
think that there are many challenges
that with that that remain and really
primarily there are really huge
bioinformatics challenges in the sense
that as I showed you with the balamuthia
case that really this test is only good
as a reference databases and I am I
encourage though by the fact that there
are now efforts to really expand and
really make accurate the databases that
will be available for doing this type of
sequencing analysis analysis so I think
that the the generation of these
databases will go a line will go in
parallel will be will go in parallel
with development of the technology
itself the other barrier I see is that
of clinical validation you need to show
that this technique can be used clinic
and by using clinically you have to show
that it's accurate it's sensitive its
specific that you get results that can
be interpreted by physicians and because
of the computational challenges and
about informatics challenges and the
technical challenges this has been
difficult but but I think that over the
next 10 years what you're going to see
is you're going to see that that the all
of the hard work with development has
already been done and now it's really
going to be time to implement this in
practically well thank you talk to chew
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing to share or a 2016
you'll receive an email from lab roots
alerting you in this webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
afford that announcement to your
colleagues you may have missed today's
live event see you next time bye